un grand merci aussi yannick fialip ou
aux républicains on n'a pas du tout
envie de baisser les bras par rapport à
l'agriculture donc merci de ce
témoignage alors sur les charges et sur
les normes je crois que la filière
porcine des choses à dire oui bien sûr
bonjour à tous donc merci pour votre
invitation
et je dirais en préambule qu en vingt
ans de syndicalisme c'est la première
fois que je suis invité dans un
dans une rencontre avec un parti
politique tout ça pour dire que il ya un
vrai problème en france de travail en
amont des enjeux politiques et
économiques de ce pays
le travail devrait se faire beaucoup
plus tôt entre les différents partis en
charge du goût des différents
gouvernements et les syndicats agricoles
pour qu'on puisse élaborer des un
programme qui soit partagé par tous ça
c'est un vrai sujet voilà donc - paul
auffray je suis éleveur dans les côtes
d'armor donc à l'arrêt dans la région de
saint-brieuc jeu j'ai la particularité
de travailler sur trois sites
d'exploitation 300 sites et c'est pas un
hasard donc le fait d'avoir délibérément
choisir deux sur trois sites c'est tout
simplement à cause des règles
administratives et du fait que depuis
que je suis installé depuis 1990 dès les
premières semaines de mon installation
j'étais quasiment dans une situation de
paralysie de développement donc il a
fallu faire autrement donc aujourd'hui
le mât structure d'exploitation au titre
personnel n'est pas un choix délibéré
c'est un choix subi mais qui coûte très
cher cantonnerait trois sites assurent
un rayon de 50 km je peux vous dire
qu'en termes de management c'est très
compliqué voilà donc je suis président
de la fédération nationale porcine
depuis un peu moins de deux ans est donc
très honnêtement la lune de miel a duré
trois mois trois mois et depuis
septembre 2014
on va dire que ont subi une crise de
très grande ampleur
et pour pour mémoire je ne suis pas sûr
que qui est beaucoup de producteurs en
activité qui est büchi connu cette
situation depuis lors des de la ville de
boulder carrière donc comme le disait
yannick tout à l'heure l'élevage en
france est en danger pour le dire on
pense que parce qu'il ya des vaches dans
les champs un peu partout que c'est
immuable c'est pas vrai tout ça ça peut
s'arrêter du jour au lendemain
vous savez quand l'agriculteur décide de
jeter l'épongé le cheptel disparaît dans
les quinze jours
voilà donc la particularité c'est que
toutes les productions aujourd'hui sont
touchés qu'elle soit animale ou végétale
ça c'est un fait
il ya quelques productions qui tirent
leur épingle du jeu pour d'autres
raisons et particulièrement la pile la
production porcine est en crise depuis
2007 depuis septembre 2007
ça va faire près de 10 en 10 ans avec
quelques périodes de répit c'est vrai
mais moi ça fait presque dix ans que
j'ai pas fait un bilan positif
vous allez me dire comment comment je
fais pour tenir c'est que quand on a 25
26 ans de carrière on a eu la chance
d'avoir mis un peu de côté d'avoir
plutôt bien géré et aujourd'hui on serre
les boulons
on a consommé pour beaucoup l'ensemble
des capitaux qu'on avait mis de côté
on a pour beaucoup aussi opérer un
certain nombre de restructurations
financières avec nos banquiers et
aujourd'hui on s'en est on s'en est donc
à l'heure où je vous parle
un producteur de porcs via il ya
aujourd'hui en france environ six mille
producteurs de porcs spécialisé sur une
population qui tourne autour de 10 mille
quand on compte tous les éleveurs de
porcs qui sont sur plusieurs productions
donc six mille éleveurs spécialisés la
moyenne c'est 200 truies naisseur
engraisseur une cinquantaine d'hectares
donc autant dire ce sont des
exploitations de taille familiale de
taille de taille moyenne à dimension
veille à capitaux familiaux qui sort
environ 5000 porcs charcutiers par an
alors pour ceux qui connaissent pas le
milieu ça fait beaucoup
ça fait même sa une petite connotation
industriels pour tout vous dire c'est
dix fois moins que les tailles
d'ateliers américain à peu près autant à
peu près 10 fois moins que les tailles
d'ateliers espagnol est aujourd'hui deux
à trois fois moins grande que les
ateliers allemands hollandais et danois
donc aujourd'hui sans vouloir dire que
la taille et le seul critère de
rentabilité
je pense malgré tout qu'il en fait
partie
les économies d'échelle se font aussi
sur la taille mais encore une fois ne me
faites pas dire que sous prétexte que
vous êtes grandissent et votre
exploitation vous êtes forcément
rentable la réalité d'aujourd'hui vous
montre que que les difficultés
financières se rencontrent chez des
éleveurs de petites dimensions de
dimension moyenne
mais aussi fait nouveau des grandes
exploitations et je peux vous dire que
quand des exploitations porcines de
grandes dimensions met à genoux par
terre ça fait du bruit c'est pas 50
millions c'est pas cinquante mille euros
de déficit c'est j'en connais une ou
deux par exemple qui ont déposé le bilan
dernièrement ccd trou qui vont de cinq
cent mille à 2 millions d'euros sur une
seule tête
voyez ce que ça peut faire donc dans ces
cas là le gars qui perd son entreprise
les ouvriers sont au chômage
il perd sa maison et souvent ça se
termine en divorce voilà donc voilà et
les gens sont la rue à la rue ça c'est
la réalité
donc aujourd'hui entre les prix qu'on a
connue pendant l'été qui était autour
d'un euro 40 qui était à peu près
l'equilibre de prix qui était
souhaitable pour pouvoir équilibrer
aujourd'hui il manque 30 centimes 30
centimes on est aujourd'hui à 1 09 vous
rajoutez bien entendu la plus-value
qualité mais en tous les cas aujourd'hui
un éleveur de pur moyens français qui
produit cinq mille cochons par an il
perd dix mille euros par mois donc ça ça
peut pas durer ça peut pas durer et
aujourd'hui quand vous grand interroger
les les techniciens des centres de
gestion ou des champs de riz nul turquie
qui suivent ces affaires là en côtes
d'armor en particulier c'est au minimum
un dépôt de bilan d'un dépôt de bilan
par semaine voilà tout ça tout ça avec
comme l'a dit yannick des éleveurs qui
font partie des éleveurs les plus
compétitifs d'europe
rien que sur le critère comment dire
alimentation 20 % de gain alimentaire en
20 ans 15 ans 20 % de gain alimentaire
en quinze ans c'est à dire on utilise
20% d'aliments deux mois pour produire
un kilo de viande 30 % de gain de plus
par truie pro 15 ans 50% de production
et de productivité en plus paru th
donc un producteur de porcs aujourd'hui
produit 50% de viande de plus qu'il ya
quinze ans c'est tout simplement ce qui
se fait de mieux en europe
tout ça avec un pack bâtiment fatigué
alors autant vous dire que si on avait
investi les trois milliards d'euros qui
nous manque aujourd'hui en matière de
rénovation ou de modernisation de nos
élevages
on serait encore meilleur et on serait
d'autant plus meilleure qu'en faisant du
bâtiment neuf on répondrait encore un
peu mieux aux aspirations sociétale
quand vous faites du bâtiment neuf vous
gérez les problèmes d'énergie
aujourd'hui on fait des porcheries
impact positif à énergie positive
on sait faire ça on fait des bâtiments
sans lisier on sait faire ça on est
quasiment les seuls à faire ça on fait
des bâtiments sans rejet d'ammoniac
on sait faire ça aussi et donc quand
vous combinez tout ça vous rajoutez à ça
tous les conditions de travail et ainsi
de suite quand on sait faire ça on
augmente systématiquement la
productivité du travail la productivité
des animaux et surtout on améliore la
santé des animaux
donc la santé des consommateurs ça en
l'oubli est-ce que vous restez pour la
première la deuxième table ronde et
pipolo frais quand on lance c'est
difficile de l'arrêter
moi je vous remercie tous les trois
juges jouera juste amaury jacques fabre
à gauche deux mots quand même je
voudrais dénoncer quand même une forme
d'anarchie
organisé par la commission européenne
avec la caution des gouvernements
européens qui consiste aujourd'hui à
avoir détricoter toute la politique
agricole commune
parce que même si les moyens financiers
importants
le fait d'avoir accepté
des règles fiscales différentes d'un
pays à l'autre le fait d'avoir accordé
le statut des travailleurs détachés le
fait d'avoir des idées différentes
sociétés sociale sur les continents
européen c'est aujourd'hui une forme de
détricotage la delà de la politique
agricole commune
ça c'est un premier point et deuxième
point la france a continué alourdir les
charges aux producteurs donc aujourd'hui
les verts se trouvait entre le marteau
et l'enclume donc produire plus cher
dans une europe toujours plus libérale
c'est mission impossible
donc il faut absolument un qu'on remette
les pieds à bruxelles que la france d'un
v6 bruxelles c'est à dire les politiques
mais aussi la profession mais aussi la
profession on est complètement absent
bruxelles on est complètement absent
bruxelles et puis forcément je sais pas
s'il faut dégraisser le mammouth en
france mais en tous les cas les
contrôles ras-le-bol ras-le-bol d'être
suspecté d'être tout le temps rien qu'en
donc voilà donc
donc il faut retrouver de la
compétitivité en france et surtout de
retrouver un cadre européen qui soit
cette fois ci beaucoup plus juste est
beaucoup plus stable pour l'ensemble des
producteurs français mais surtout
européens